so let's consider I'm not necessary
let's consider N equals 3 ok coupe now
for reasons that will become clear in
that minute i'm going to write this guy
over here on the left-hand side instead
of right hand side so i'm going to go
cos 3 theta plus i sine 3 feet are right
it's going to be equal to that guy on
the left hand side
cute okay now the reason why I've
written that part on the right hand side
is because when we're doing our working
in a second all the business is going to
be happening on the right hand side the
left hand side is just going to stay
where it it ok now this presents a new
problem to us right in order to make
progress here we called on trig
identities right and so we can
substitute them all the way through I
want you to have a careful look at that
thing on the right hand side the first
corner of the whiteboard what piece of
knowledge do you have that allows you to
make mincemeat of that expansion just do
it in one hit Pascal's triangle right in
Pascal's triangle you've got all the
binomial coefficients and because this
is a nice easy one right it goes 1 11 12
1 what's the next one 13 13 31 ok up to
14 641 you should be able to just do
straddle your head so let's have a gone
right what you're gonna have this is a
plus B or cute so this is our ends up in
ok I'm going to get 1 33 11 33 1 and I
just have very empowers of these so the
first one is going to be caused cubed
theta do you agree that is one of those
the next one I've got three of them
three of what
cos squared so not power clients down
and then I get a nice sign thing go do
you agree that I get one of those yep so
far so good I've done one I've done
three now I should have another 33 of
one can call this theta I just pump I
will get to they use in a second i'm
just doing the expansion straight out
now I've got two of these right so
that's going to be i square sine square
yeah you're with me I've got one and
then three and then three and then 11
what I cute sine cubed okay cool so you
used binomial theorem to make mincemeat
of that that was great that was easy and
what can I do here the thing we were
going after if they were going after
side 3 theta how do you see that where
is so 3d I what I'm doing here
sime 3 theta is the imaginary part of
the left-hand side do you agree so
therefore it should exactly line up with
the imaginary part of the right-hand
side so now my job is to take this which
is something of a mess at the moment and
sort out which are the real bits and
which are the imaginary bits you see
that's where I'm going that's my
trajectory okay so let's have a go tell
me which are the real components first
we'll just gather them in one spot all
right cause cute is clearly a real part
what else is real like that is real
isn't it right this has got an eye in
there and it can't cancel out this has
got too many eyes and hair okay so you
can slap but this is just going to
become minus 1 98 one so let's write
that that's minus 3 cos theta sine
squared you agree is the real bit let's
say that the imaginary bit now I'm going
to take out that factor of my that'll
make the comparison a bit easier and a
seventh
I already got this bit right 3 cos
squared sine does that look familiar
three cod squared side so i'll write
that down there and here if i take out
one of the eyes what's left behind two
of them which is minus one right so that
means minus sign cute hub does that look
familiar ok so we've just confirmed this
result here without having to appeal to
any of these guys over here did you
notice that right you didn't need to
know any of this in order for this to
emerge so what happens reviewable we can
do a little bit of tidying up right in
fact what I'll do is we're going to do
this separately to pieces now so your
next line will say comparing the real
and imaginary components we pulled this
trick out when we're doing square roots
of complex numbers if you recall that
okay so we'll do the real bits first
real cuz to be thinner over here on the
left I wind up my party now do you see
this is a cosine so I think I want to
get all of these in cosines okay now
just be a bit neater so cause cubed
minus 3 cos theta what would you like me
to replace with I want to get rid of all
the sides i can i'm going to replace
with 1 minus cos square
ok tiny a little bit of tidying up here
so this looks like it's 3 cos theta plus
3 cos cubed Thea that look good for
cause huge feet up minus 30 and at this
point if I hadn't have done this earlier
I would have said imaginary part science
read data equals etc but you can see
we've actually already done this like we
did this 10 minutes ago so we know we're
gonna we had this line so we're going to
get to this line so I'm going to say
that just to conclude
okay so there is the first what are you
doing here right complex numbers here
what does this have to do with complex
numbers what complex numbers have this
way of reaching into everything so you
can see I have confirmed these results
which are completely to do with real
angles and I've demonstrated easier than
wireless theorem okay so that's pretty
awesome it's also nice that these two
the cost to be thinner the triple hang
results were both come out at the same
time right and you can also see this
really lovely symmetry between the
Kaiser azhar and the same result do you
see that you see how each kind of match
nicely so that's kind of fancy okay one
more thing before we leave off this
right do you remember the key piece of
information to go shoot from here to
here what was it again what was it it
was passives triangle was binomial
theorem giving you the binomial
coefficients now there's one other spot
on the board right now where there are
binomial coefficients you're just not
used to spotting them that way do you
see them yeah look we said here that is
the binomial coefficients right now we
just use this one because it was cute
okay but you just look at the previous
row which is about swearing or as we
would say doubling the angles look one
to one why is that a minus sign why is
that negative
because there's a nice square there is a
nice Quincy just like over here right so
it's like how complex numbers then
they're all along right it's quite
amazing